hey Tom Tom go ahead yeah Tom Cavanagh
we are talking it's funny we're just
going over sitcoms and stuff and when
you walked in we're talking about Gary
Marshall and some of the ones he did
were good and there was a couple of bad
ones up and I kind of I kind of feel
like he'd he did more damage to sitcoms
than anybody shot yeah yeah Wow more
damage this damaged your position
counselor well we were just watching
Mork from ork visit happy days yeah I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you doing Gary
but like you know you can you weigh in
on this that'd be more like there
wouldn't that be like sign of the times
kind of thing a little bit part of it
was yeah he did it he did a lot for I
guess a certain genre system Norman Lear
like writing like actual show yes that
actually talked about stuff yeah sure
but yeah like you know Garry Marshalls
like a Big Bang Theory a big old country
right now yeah but I was watching what's
it called Mike in the chimney and the
chimp me and the chimp was a show from
1972 that went one year and we just
watched the opening it's so bad yeah
what you want to do is be in that
picture room I think so it's a chimp in
me right that's not far so that's not
far from one of ones we just read it was
Maya dentist Mike Reynolds and someone
finds a chimp and the antics ensue and
that became a show yeah we were watching
like the opening credits and it is just
a guy like I'm trying to hose off the
lawn but there's a chimp here tom
foolery
don't you see folks in the chimp we can
go 10 seasons with this everything is
more difficult with a chimp in hilarious
you ever work with an item I worked with
a chimp on he's a pilot for MTV in 2003
was awful and my co-star was a chimp
named Mikey actual gentleman yeah an
actual chip it was kind of cool to do
and I'm actually on a one of Louie's
episodes we had a chimp but it didn't
make the air because Nick DiPaolo was
supposed to get angry and scream but
they couldn't have the chimp in the room
to like the chimp will attack you if you
show that kind of aggression yeah so
they had to shoot it separately and it
was a whole [ __ ] mess so twice I've
worked with chimps you never worked with
an animal I
oh yeah that's the old adage right don't
you know no kids or chimps right that's
what they say yeah and no don't shoot on
the water to anything after Jaws that
became a thing or so yeah that's like
eight pages a day or like 1/8 of a day
depending on where you're shooting I
remember I do remember one time doing a
movie where there was a cage of chimps
and we had a we had to go by that cage
of chimps and they were just like
throwing crap at us oh this is our day
they're like they couldn't believe it go
look there's film cameras and people
want they want guys they walk right by
Splatt Splatt imagine if the chimps
understood there's a camera and we can
throw [ __ ] at these people need more
food we need to make more [ __ ] all day
they film all day so look like artillery
ready to go what was the project oh gosh
I remember just like 1940 but when we
work together way back then I didn't
think you'd remember cuz I had a small
part on show dude like that when he came
on it was like legends because you know
Mitch was there you were there was just
like it was just like oh my god these
guys are you kidding me like there was
doing that show with the show that you
worked on was like a non-stop cavalcade
of like regular cast who were nobodies
like me and just a just a bunch of
nobodies and then the guys who did the
show were the Letterman people and they
brought on their favorite people and I
felt like you guys were there like Mitch
and Jim and John Goodman did the show
like that any I think they brought in
like the guys that like owed them
something I really had the sense I
listened you can either do these
appearances or you can come to our show
and we'll pay you handsomely and then we
always felt like okay that they somehow
these guys lost a bet and now they have
to come and do it recently that you're
on the episode three or four you have
three early on really because the show
got huge no I mean I mean it have pretty
boys is edie panel made a pretty real if
I was again like back in the in the day
like it had like you know good like 1012
million nowadays people would lose their
minds back then then it was like I don't
know like everybody was horribly tuned
in to TV Mike star was in that
really good you know Mike stars Sam he's
a you've seen him a million times he's
in everything Goodfellas Miller's
Crossing Miller's Crossing you've seen
that yeah the guy when Adrian when the
guide the main guide bust a big lugs
nose the thing that's Mike star good he
plays he plays the he's the guy that
that Ray Liotta and De Niro are talking
to and he's like what about the security
goes security you're looking at he's in
every [ __ ] song Nicholson I when I
first met him I'm like I know I gotta
know his neighbor's not like I know you
I know you probably you want my resume
that was incredibly well-connected it
was just like every name in the book
like you know so and so and he after a
while I was like this is this show is
not good enough for me here on I think
he did a year or two but then he was
just like it he had Mike star was one of
those guys are like for that what'd he
look like in his talent ability
everybody wanted
so is that stressful then back then when
like you're getting 1012 million viewers
and it's still every season you don't
know if they're gonna pick you up no I
mean you're like I can see why it might
be stressful we were like literally
there was like because we're there was
west wing doors NBC had big shows
friends and then it was us and Rob
Burnett the who's one of my all-time
greatest friends he was just like he
would always say like we just got in
under the radar like that show was about
a bowling alley lawyer yeah and it was
an hour of television time everyone's
like what you show is an hour yeah yeah
and you're like what were you thinking
like an hour worth of you know for four
years you just lost their minds
like nowadays he'd be like haha no but
what really do you have to give us and
whether it wasn't a wacky sitcom it was
like our drama that was an hour Michael
Ian Black was very good in that show I
forgot that was an hour yeah like they
it was the Letterman guys so they they
had game like they really like Rob
Burnett and John back really like sharp
sharp writers and they also had like
that ability to do the heart thing but
nowadays that would be if they didn't do
minutes there's just no way a show like
that would last in who's ever talking
about knocking it down to a half-hour to
make it cheaper I think when they were
making it they were making it for CBS
initially and I think those guys at some
point there was a half-hour version of
it but back in the day they're like no
you're you know you're Letterman you
guys want to do it out long yeah okay
great
let's do it as they talked about a
reunion or a reboot or anything like
that because I'm a because like Will and
Grace is back on and Netflix just they
never come out with data right but the
the one thing that they put out was they
put out how the the rankings of which
shows were viewed the most times within
24 hours of being released like binge
and Gilmore Girls was number one well
yeah they're there additional Gilmore
Girls season that they did exclusively
for Netflix was enormous yeah that felt
like a sister show for us they were on a
you know they're their numbers were were
much smaller they were in a smaller
Network but they had a loyal following
and we had the same thing on a larger
network but I think you know they
Gilmore Girls I can see why they want to
reboot or what was the Veronica Mars
right Will and Grace you know but no
nobody wants to do anybody wants to like
see like hey what's a forty
five-year-old add up to like I just
don't think there's I haven't heard a
single thing like maybe from the
die-hard fans you know they're like
right we know we should do bring back
and there's like four of them you know
and they're all so semi related to us
you know I don't think that there's a
clamor or a demand for that thank God
for the flash then right I asked Eric
McCormack I asked him I was like I'm
like so are you who's paying who come
back and do that show again you are by
the way I wanna see you only got yeah
eighty-three episodes that have had for
four years
so you missed syndication by 17 episodes
I mean that's it's like it's not like
they missed it by two and again like I
know that you know exactly but at the
same time it was a very weird thing was
just like we really proceeded from
gratitude as obnoxious as that sounds
we're like another year we just you know
we so after four seasons and what cuz I
was like you always hear that but then
you kind of get a little bit married to
the
yeah this is happening again so when it
doesn't happen again as much as you want
to be like I wasn't even supposed to so
we're happy I think you're kind of I
think you're exactly right but for some
reason we had a Rob and I we talked
about this on before this thing even
aired that if we got four years holy cow
we never kind of lost sight of like if
we got four years like nobody wants to
be on this you know on the downside it
kind of felt like that was one of those
rare shows that like we ended with a
marriage you know we were still wanted
and I think that you don't want to be
sticking around when you're not one a
hard as it is to leave for years felt
like great that's phenomenal and I you
wouldn't know more about this than me
Jim but it felt like syndication was
changing then like like five years
earlier if you got like that you know
that big number then you were gonna be
like oh you're gonna be Seinfeld you're
gonna be rich but I don't think that was
ever gonna be our case you know that
haha we have the ed money to rely maybe
not yeah yeah how do they tell you you
were canceled I always like to know that
like how did you find out every
literally every year it felt like the
you know the sword of Damocles was
hanging over our head we just felt like
every year we just oh we're back that's
great you know like they never it's
funny because then when a network under
undergoes a regime change then they're
the the new president was like you're
not ours right now and we had we had one
or two guys like you know shepherding us
along and then those guys were gone
there was another person and that was
gone then Zucker was there and you know
I think a lot of those guys were just
like yeah if we could just manage to get
this hour off the air but the numbers
were solid enough that it was kind of
nowadays they just canceled you they'd
be like yeah we don't care we don't care
about numbers or backlash or anything
back then there was a certainty that
mike omalley kind of felt like and I
like you know I'm sure you know Mike
Mike and Mike did a mike omalley show
that was yeah touted and Heather Graham
did a show that was really touted and
they sunk all the money into the promos
and then you know the numbers weren't
where they want them so they canceled
them after like an episode or two and
back then I was like what how could you
sink all this money and do all your
research and then take them off the air
don't you look like fools and then it
became like we don't care yeah there's
no the once there's no pay back now is
just Ellis cancel any having the waiting
they spell like a shitload of money on
promo I remember being in LA and seeing
[ __ ] all over
the size posters of her and Chris D'Elia
and then they can't show anything on the
internet without seeing coming on first
yeah and she uh she said that they
canceled she knew that they weren't
coming back or whatever how many
episodes they did they might have been
done a full season a dutiful sorry okay
and then crystally I think they offered
something else too undateable I thought
it was yeah and then she like oh when it
was live what was undateable I know this
trouble was about they just bunch of it
was comics Ron Funches it was on Ron
franchise and brent morin and yeah there
was just a bunch of guys who you know
we're basically in a bar like Brent and
Chris were roommates and literally I
remember on the episode that I did there
was like a you know Chris does such a
good drunk and they were like oh you
know what it felt like the the bridge
between like studio audience which is
what I did but then halfway through my
show bill Lawrence the showrunner walked
in he was like all right you know what
let's change this you're gonna come in
and you're you want to do this and then
you and it would just became this live
thing and the eye and he was just like
bill was so quick with this stuff you're
gonna do this you're gonna come in Chris
you're drunk and then it just ended up
being this big long kind of thing
they're like this is money why would we
like script it and so then it became
basically the live person they went on
tour they did a stand-up tour across
America like they literally started
doing it started as a sitcom and then it
became alive like every Friday night or
whatever that or whatever night it was
on that half hour was they did it live
those guys were yeah how many years are
the last two okay I think all told like
the width the scripted and then the live
version combined two years yeah yeah
that's gotta be heartbreaking I guess
Steve Burns a friend of mine and he had
that show called Sullivan & Son I think
lasted two seasons TBS right I used on
TBS but it's just it's kind of just suck
like you think okay this is it this is
good and then like yeah it's just yeah
you think you got mash for a cycle and
then they just take it away for whatever
reason it's like ah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it can be heartbreaking
did you after that did you have a hard
time like did you say okay I want to get
something else just like this and then
you're fighting for that or did you have
a down time where you're like you know
no I in the back in a day they were like
I'm Canadian so I was like I thought
Edie was over I'd done like Providence
before that but it was like the first
kind of larger profile thing where we
were just you know assaulted with like
you know like the promos and the media
and that kind of thing it was like part
of a part of a big deal but being
Canadian having done a decade worth a
theater
I just thought once this is over because
that's the Canadian experience you can
do like I remember people from some of
the longest-running shows you know
beachcombers and street legal up in
Canada which mean like 17 years or
something like that you know those guys
were then like well I'm auditioning for
you know you know the part of the guys
best friend on you know they were just
like they went back into the bread line
and in America that it doesn't work that
way once you've like you know you've
been promoted you kind of stay right at
a certain at a certain level I was not
expecting that I was like right I'm
gonna go like maybe maybe Matthew
Perry's got like a best friend that
shows up every fourth before the episode
I'll be that guy you know I mean but it
wasn't I found that when I came out it
was a whole different shift and so yeah
so yeah they were just saying you would
you want to do this this this and this
and being a living in New York I did it
a show about a musical a guy who's like
an A&R rep a small A&R rep that lasted
like maybe four seconds
that actually is a decent show about
like when you talk about getting your
heart broken I really like that show
because we had it was about a music file
as a guy who's like small you know sign
and like small acts but every act beat
every episode we have like a Ben Folds
and then an up-and-coming person who an
unheard-of person and then like John
Cougar you know like so and literally
like half year episode you know if you
like music which is like this is this is
a dream you know the Apple were great
Judy Greer who's like phenomenally
talented and I were like sort of love
interest they were a really tremendous
group run by this guy Michael Roush was
like one of the greatest human beings in
showbiz like an actual good human being
and it I was on Conan and I was getting
ready to promo it goes on that because
it was on that night like I'm in the
green room there's a knock on the door
and I think it's like ah hey we're ready
for you Jim and it's Michael and he's
like hey so they pulled us
and Lily are the only reason as you know
the only reason you're on like Conan or
Jo shows the letter minutes just to talk
about the project the project right and
so next knock on the door is Conan going
hey so I'm cool if you want to leave but
I have you for a double segment and I
got no one else you know and do you want
to go on I heard that you just got axed
and I'm just like yeah no I'll go on and
he we're literally walking out and
they're like you know the band's
starting to play and he goes should we
talk about the thing I'm like I don't
know if I I might not know what I'm I
might not say the right thing you know
like let's talk about anything so
literally we sit down and all we were
gonna talk about was music and love
mugging we sit down and Conan goes do
you live in New York right I'm like yeah
he's like you bike right you're the part
I thought those bikers and literally
like there was two segments of like but
it was one of the funnest times on the
show cuz he was you know he's so quick
and funny and he we just made stuff up
you know you don't worry about it
promoting anything but there's no yours
now just hanging out on a TV and then I
was doing like a show a theater piece
and Conan had me on like six months
later he's like now we're talking about
like oh yeah that story and the audience
was like what writing about to go on
yeah and you know everybody gets those
memos about you know Jim Norton is on
the show tonight and this kind of thing
they would have somebody would have had
that it would have had to know yet
they're like yeah that's catalyst I
would have been [ __ ] Peter Fincham
Network on that first appearance I would
have melted down publicly and had a
major problem yeah I never would have
held that you would have you would have
been outraged and like you're just
complaining you haven't heard at the
same thing though when he was at the
upfront
they told him like when they're about to
announce him in his new show that they
said oh no no we but they pulled the
show his agent goes cavanaugh know
what's going on he talked about in his
book yeah and say then show business
builds crazy except so cruel they don't
they tell him when he's there you're not
going onstage because it's over the show
is not being made and then he snuck into
the up-front parties anyway okay and he
went and just experienced it cuz he's
got a pretty positive attitude which
again I don't I envy that I envy the
ability
blowtorch yeah I have the ability to go
out there and be funny on Conan good for
you I mean for them to tell you right
there it was crazy it was like that
Lilly was I thought it was a segment
producer going hey let's
go so and then it was like you know when
you're done and when you think I
remember like parsing that it was all
happened so quickly right but I remember
thinking backwards how good of him to
like grab a cab come uptown knock on the
door himself to tell me to breathe air
as opposed to like hey buddy just so you
know sure
you sound like yeah yeah otherwise you
tape it it's gonna get out that the
shows cancelled but and then you're on
promoting this show that everybody knows
is cancelled and they're like you know
the little bumps harden you to the
business meaning that you know cuz
obviously the only people who do this
stuff it's like their dream and their
passion and like you know you get
there's all this joy that comes with the
success of it but then just like that
just some guy at the worst possible -
come see and be like yeah that's not
happening like this whole thing that you
spent weeks thinking about and you're
about to go on TV to talk about it's all
over goodbye yeah and like you have to
go from you know a2w yeah I think it's
like any other walk of life like what
you're like where your [ __ ] meter is
you know it's like there's I don't know
how many times I walked in this guy's
not telling me the truth
dude I mean like you just so over the
years you meet these people you're like
nope nope nope no yes you know what I
mean I think that every time I walk in a
room and someone says good to see ya
[ __ ] liar comfortable with a gig like
do you have I have a phrase where it's
like and I think it serves serves well
especially I'm doing the flash now with
a bunch of younger writers I remember
the beginning you know because I was
that way too you know you're like oh my
gosh I can't believe it were you know
everyone's treating us so well you know
and they really like us and you know I
gathered them and I remember okay four
words they're not your friends yeah I
mean and it's just literally that serve
me was I don't I don't take offense you
know but I also like you're not my
friend you'll fire me in a heart right
when this thing I don't have any
expectations but at the same time I
ranch you know we're gonna be great it's
gonna be great while it's going well
it's gonna bring enemies you're not my
friend we're not enemies like you're
gonna like I I'm a realistic so I'm not
going to do you favors and you know
sacrifice any dignity for you because at
the end of the day you
just gonna be like I served your purpose
right next gig yeah exactly I get that
what so are you happy you've got to be
happy I was thinking about you being on
the flash because your character like
consistently dies and then comes back to
somebody else so it's like you get to
this thing in the script yeah where
you're like oh no I'm dying and then you
get the next script and be like oh great
yeah I just I just saw that
you'll talk about that later anyway uh
Al Franken it had breasts in it and I
was like yeah I'd love to take those
pictures with her would you love to
you've a crush on Ariana's sex yeah yeah
I see the thing on Leno with her every
weekend once every other week or yeah
she's sexy I started riding a bicycle
one time I mean I wasn't turned on I was
just like hey I just kept walking about
the show yeah a flash in the flash but
anyway no so the great thing about the
flash is just like you know so I'm the
the character that I consistently play
is the reverse-flash and so he's the
Nemesis of the flash the flash wears a
red suit reverse-flash wears a yellow
suit I felt like you know that box was
never gonna get checked you know and
then suddenly superheroes were huge and
next thing you know I'm a guy who's
getting tailored for a yellow super suit
you know what it means everything yeah
it's kind of crazy great because that
reverse flash is there Lex Luthor if you
know for comic book fans you know that's
a the reverse flash is a big deal in
that world right and so to be that that
guy you know for these for these fans
was like that was like really are you
kidding me and then we found out pretty
early on that you can't just you can't
have the flash battle the reverse flash
all the time it's because it's you know
when I do it I you know I do the voices
down here you know it's like you'll
never get me flash well we will fight
for centuries they fight they fight for
like hundred like years and years and
years right chasing each oh my god and
so in the first season we did a thing
where I'm playing the guy in a wheel
but he's actually the reverse-flash and
you don't know and be grateful then
afterwards we were like huh I guess we
can't really the whole season was like
unveiling that was actually me that's
episode 11 episode 15 I killed one of
the leads you know episode 22 the flash
finds out but 23 we we fight he wins
because he's the flash you know and so
then we're like so season 2 repeat and
so they're like we can't do that and I
was like what if I play a guy who looks
like a bad guy he's not so we did that
then season 3 I got tired of that so I
was like well what do I play a comedy
guy so we did that Susan for I'm like
you know doing other things and but it's
reverse-flash totally gone no no no
that's the great thing is I saw it on
any given episode I'll play you know two
characters I'll play like the funny guy
or all play like the guy from like you
know earth 2 or I'll play the
reverse-flash you know there's always
that there's always the possibility that
that guy's going to come back and start
kicking the [ __ ] out of Barry Allen
which is great David Lynch series yeah
it's great yeah it's probably good it's
good yeah it's like the the nice thing
about doing one of these shows is like
so that the trope they've set up is that
for every earth there's like there's
another earth with your doppelgangers in
it but they're not you know they're not
organized guys they're like they're they
look exactly like you that's right but
you can be anything you want literally
it's like you know what I come from
Earth 24 I mean and so it's great it's
got to keep it from getting boring
you're doing all this difference that
because if you're lucky you have to be
in a long-running show normally it's
like hey Sam Malone on Cheers which is
great you know at the same time it's
like but imagine if there are years in
Malt like infinity earths with infinity
Sam Malone's you know whatever Sam
Malone comes in and he's killing people
yeah great are do that see that cutie
pie right over there in the corner he is
a his name's Rob and he is a massive fan
of the flash oh is that right I like all
of them
you know legend tomorrow era but the
flash is by far the best your favorite
100% get good your characters on it are
awesome yeah do you like Tom in the show
love them HR was the best you clearly do
what oh yeah earth 19 HR HR was a con
man kind of like an Owen Wilson kind of
tell great can I have your shirt that's
amazing could I have your shirt like
you know it's just by the way this is
this is how pathetic I am for a second
when he said you look great I was I
wanted to say thank you that's what a
great actor he almost oh thank God you
moved on or I would have just thought
thanks dude I would see who wins in a
fight reverse flash or arrow Stephen
Amell arrow Oh reverse flash good 100%
the reverse flash is like that guy's
like I mean not because I play it but
just in the thing like that guys like me
had a vibrating hand speed of light like
he's just like vibrating and he's coming
[Laughter]